>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Anne McLean: Good evening.
I'm Anne McLean from the
Library's concert office.
With this talk, I'm delighted
to be officially opening the
90th anniversary celebration
of the Library's concert series.
We're celebrating nine
decades of splendid concerts,
a long and storied legacy.
Coming up, a terrific and
very exciting 90 weeks
of celebration starting tonight.
We have a stunning
line-up of concerts
and events reflecting our
past, and we're looking ahead
to a very strong and
exhilarating future.
As insiders and good
friends, you're the first
to get a mini sneak
preview of our celebration
which will continue
through September 2016.
We have quite a lot to celebrate
including the three jewels
of our series.
Which are the superb
auditorium, our rare instruments,
and the vast expanse of the
music division's collections.
Nearly 22 million items.
More than 500 commissions including
landmark works by Maurice Ravel,
Bayla [phonetic] Bartaugh,
Arnold Schoenberg,
Aaron Copeland, and many, many more.
Warm relationships, a theme of
this talk, and a huge roster
of towering musical figures
from several generations.
Plus, a very sophisticated audience
which plays an important
role in our history.
Among the world's national
libraries,
we are unique in being
a major presenter.
As the nation's oldest
federal cultural institution,
the Library is also an
important actor in the realm
of cultural diplomacy,
and our concerts very
much reflect this mission.
Opus 90 seemed an appropriate
title for this talk
because our founder Elizabeth
Sprague Coolidge called her work
here the creation
of this extraordinary
series, her Magnum Opus.
It is a great work that is
still very much ongoing,
evolving as our culture evolves.
And it has continued to be
a great and absorbing work
for the many people fortunate enough
to have helped it live so vibrantly
since its founding
almost 90 years ago.
Throughout our history,
the programming has been
informed by some constants.
The intention to present concerts
of the highest artistic caliber,
the ideal of uncompromising
integrity,
and the goals of diversity
and democratic outreach.
Here are some of the questions
that we'll look into in this hour.
How did the Library of
Congress come to be the owner
and operator of a concert series?
How have we effected the development
and appreciation of
music in America?
First in classical music
and later a range of genres?
What's the story of the
concerts as a media presence?
And, finally, how does
the visionary thinking
of our predecessors inform
our strategic planning
for the future while we press
forward in new directions?
To answer these questions, we
naturally begin with Mrs. Coolidge.
A formidable lady of great
imagination, passion, intelligence,
and tremendous energy whose 150th
birthday we celebrate this season.
This is an image with an early
image of her around 1902.
Still with the dramatic big hats and
if you can see the whole picture,
a long bustle and everything.
As you'll see when we go
forward from this background,
she became a very,
very modern woman.
One that is still a
remarkable inspiration today.
Her concept, in 1925, she
endowed the Library of Congress
with our superb concert hall
and endowed a foundation
to support a free chamber
music series.
Her gift was a groundbreaking public
private partnership requiring an act
of Congress.
This concept was radical.
It was one that would
bring the nation's library
to international visibility
as a presenter
and establish a precedent
for future benefactors.
It would raise the awareness
of chamber music in America
and ensure her legacy as one of the
great music patrons of her time.
She was a fine pianist
who loved chamber music.
You see her in this grainy
image here with her son, Albert.
She was a lifelong
student of composition
and published some pieces.
She had one piece published
by G Shermer.
That work which was a set of Mother
Goose songs was also recorded,
and you can see in here a
Victor [inaudible] of that.
She wrote a string quartet
and an oboe and piano sonata,
a number of pieces which we have
here and have had played through
and one has been performed.
Had Mrs. Coolidge been from a
different social background,
she very likely would have
been a professional musician.
She would become a sophisticated
presenter, a true impresario
with excellent taste and
the highest standards.
On her arrival in Washington,
she was at 60 already well known
as the founder of the
Berkshire Festival and had begun
to commission a roster of
compositions that would help
to shape the history
of 20th century music.
Mrs. Coolidge would
build four concert halls.
This is her temple of music at
South Mountain in the Berkshires
in Pittsfield, Massachusetts.
She also funded and built
ooze well as the Coolidge,
the Sprague Music Hall at Yale
and the hall at Mills College.
Here she is with her very good
friends, the composer Frank Bridge
and his wife in Pittsfield.
I couldn't resist this picture
of the Neptune Plaza here
at the Library to place us visually
here in Washington around 1920.
Coming to Washington
and creating a new home
for her chamber music festivals here
was a daunting challenge requiring
all her experience and the
help of two important partners.
The Librarian of Congress
Herbert Putnam
and Music Division Chief Carl Engel.
Putnam was the first
professional Librarian of Congress
and also he was an attorney.
He was from the Putnam
publishing family.
Carl Engel, much younger,
born in Paris,
and educated in Germany
was multilingual,
cultivated, and very smart.
He had a strong scholarly background
imminently suited to his career
in a discipline that's
recently begun
to be known as public musicology.
This is an image of Carl Engel
with the composer Ernst Bloch.
And the little cartoon
next to it is interesting.
It shows, it gives you
a sense of something
of the relationship he
had with Mrs. Coolidge.
It refers to the Michelin Tires.
And the little figure on
the left is called Michel
and the woman's figure is Lean.
And it has to do with the pneumatic
tires which keep on going and,
you know, last forever,
durable, powerful, and so on.
And there were a lot of inside
jokes between the two of them.
Their letters are fascinating.
And if you read her
biography by Cyrilla Barr,
you really will be engaged.
Engel's warm relationship
with Mrs. Coolidge was based
on deep respect, mutual respect.
They set the artistic bar
very high from the beginning,
choosing both European and
American composers and performers
with Mrs. Coolidge
favoring the former.
My idea of service to America
does not fully embrace the Monroe
Doctrine, she wrote to him.
These two area [inaudible]
but practical gentlemen
helped her make a foray
into Washington cultural circles.
Her three successful
concerts at the Freer Gallery
in 1924 would open
the door to her goal
of finding a permanent government
home base for her festivals.
Briskly moving forward, she
presented an unprecedented idea
to establish a concert series
within the libraries of Congress.
Both the librarian and the Congress
had to be persuaded she said later.
She possessed powerful
skills of persuasion.
In the long run, as the composer
Daniel Gregory Mason said,
people usually did what
Mrs. Coolidge wanted.
It would be an unbelievably short
five minutes from her letter
of intent to the final signature
from President Coolidge.
This is the bill, and today is
the very day, 90 years to the day,
that Calvin Coolidge
signed this bill into law.
Already today, we have talked
about this for an interview
with St. Lawrence quartet which
is premiering a new work tonight
in the Washington premier
of a new co-commission
by John Adams which you'll hear.
And we talked about this fact and
how exciting it was 90 years today.
And the resolution
says to accept the gift
of Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge for
the construction of an auditorium
in connection with the Library
of Congress and to provide
for the erection thereof.
So this is the shot built as you
know right in the courtyard there.
They simply started
building from the ground up.
From a techno file viewpoint,
Mrs. Coolidge was astonishingly
prescient.
She insisted on engaging a
team of German acousticians
and on wiring the Coolidge for
the very new medium of radio.
Thus, the very first
consent was heard
on the radio inaugurating an
astonishing 90 year tradition
of library broadcasts that
aired across the country
and developing an appreciation
for chamber music nationwide.
She believed firmly that
if you could hear the best,
you would begin to love it.
And she talked about this in
promoting the radio broadcasts.
For many decades, ours was the
longest running classical music
series on the radio.
So let's hear what Mrs.
Coolidge said herself.
>> Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge:
After some years in Pittsfield,
my chamber music festivals had grown
to such proportions and seem to be
so important that I decided to
perpetuate them by placing them
under institutional management.
Still another chance suggestion
then led me to consider the Library
of Congress as the most
desirable, personal,
and permanent administrator
of my cherished project.
Dear Carl Engel and the Library
Mr. Herbert Putnam proved deeply
sympathetic and enormously
helpful in bringing this about.
And I was not only
very glad to share
in that increasingly
heavy responsibility,
but also welcome the
opportunity to establish
in the government a little wedge
of authority in matters of art.
I think I was even kindly accused
of a little [inaudible]
and, perhaps, justly.
For I could wish for music the
same governmental protection
that is given to hygiene,
education, or public welfare.
How wonderful if we could have
in the cabinet a secretary
of fine arts.
I feel that in the course of 26
years, my concerts have developed
and guided my career as
much as I have guided them.
One idea has evolved another.
One event has grown into another.
I have followed their direction into
paths at first entirely unforeseen.
Until today I find
myself in your midst
at this festival feeling the
radiation of friendship and beauty
which chamber music broadcasts ooze
I feel the return messages augments
a thousand fold but center
in this little auditorium
in the Library of Congress.
>> Anne McLean: It's great to share
these bits of history with you.
We have a lot of them in our
archives, and over the course
of the next year, we're
going to be pulling them out
and broadcasting them, podcasting
them, and making everybody aware
of a lot of our treasures in
the history of the concerts.
Many of the famous
musicians who performed here
in Mrs. Coolidge's day
were her good friends.
And you got an idea, a little bit,
from herring her talk what
kind of a person she was.
She was warm and immensely engaged
in music making as
a private citizen.
She played chamber music with many,
many, many now legendary figures.
In Europe and in America.
She came with a great Rolodex
this is the Coolidge Medal
of Chamber Music that she created
in those early years to award
to people contributing
significantly to chamber music.
Benjamin Britain was
an early recipient.
I thought about that theory
of the great men in history.
The figures like Alexander the
Great, George Washington, and so on.
People who don't merely
participate in history,
they make it or chart it somehow.
And things would have been
very different without them.
With this highly debatable
idea in mind, it's instructive
to review some of the prime
movers we've seen here.
Magisterial interpreters
and great musical thinkers.
Our concert archives
document their contributions,
trends in composition, and
performance practices, and the shift
and sway of intellectual
and societal currents.
One such performer was Vondelon
Dovska [phonetic], a harpsichordist,
the major force in the revival
of early music and a pioneer
as was Mrs. Coolidge herself
who would present other
pioneers was Safford Cape,
Noah Greenberg, and Alfred Deller.
She also underwrote substantial
musicological research.
She was a champion of the very,
very old as well as the very new.
The famous Hampton Institute
Choir appeared here in 1926
with the composer R
Nathaniel Dett as conductor.
Their program was striking.
Renaissance music, Russian
liturgical music, French songs,
and spirituals described in that
program as Negro folk anthems.
Carl Engel had offered
Dett a commission
from the Coolidge foundation
suggesting a work for violin, piano,
saxophone, and banjo with a thought
to bring together European
tradition with American influence.
Dett returned a dignified
letter saying, quote,
any effort from the outside to
lay down rather strict lines along
which art should develop can only
result in self consciousness and,
consequently, in artistic
and in sincere results.
The 1928 Coolidge Commission
for [inaudible] brought together the
Russian-born choreographer Adolph
Bolm with Igor Stravinsky
as the composer.
Mrs. Coolidge's good friends
[inaudible] had already declined.
Bolm toured with Anna Pavlova,
created a frenzy in his solos
for the [inaudible] dances.
And Prince Igor, he would
create his own company,
and he would also bring
[inaudible] ballet ruse
to the U.S. on its second tour.
I went too far for a second.
Stravinsky would also come back to
the Library to perform on a concert
of his, just his music, in 1935.
Including his divergemento
concertino [phonetic]
at least to our [inaudible].
Bayla Bartaugh whose string
quartet number five stands as one
of the major Coolidge
commissions performed here
with Yoseph Ziggity
[phonetic] in 1940.
In a poignant and historic concert
that holds a place in the heart
of every Hungarian still today.
This shows the program as signed
by the artist and the first page
of the Bartaugh Fifth
String Quartet.
Plus, the image of the CD
cover is a recent reissue,
and these historic recordings
do keep becoming reissued
and reissued and reissued.
It's both heartwarming
and frustrating.
It's heartwarming and
wonderful to know
that these artistic achievements
still stand and are still very,
very much admired and
in demand by people.
It's frustrating that we can't
make them available ourselves, but,
anyway, I should say
pristine classical is a firm
that has issued quite
a few of these.
Including the one we'll
talk about next.
It was the memory of
Bartaugh's performance here
that persuaded Yorgi
Cortauch [phonetic]
to accept a commission
from the Library.
Our 2009 shot shows the composer
with his wife Marta
during their performance.
Thee joined a long, long line
of composer performers here
including Hindemith, Copeland,
Barber, Bernstein, and
Kromm among many others.
Relationships here do often
run through generations.
And the Library has been
home to complete families
of musicians in some cases.
Adolph Bush and Rudolph
[inaudible], his son in law,
made their American
debuted here in 1938.
They gave a total of 21
concerts together on our stage
and also appeared separately.
For nearly 60 years the Library
enjoyed a very cordial friendship
with these founders of
the Marlboro Festival.
This is the shot of the
founders including Marcel
and Blanche [inaudible]
and Bush [inaudible], too.
The Marlboro collection
is in our archives.
One of the most influential
pedagogues of the 20th century,
Nadia Boulanger, molded
the musical perceptions
of several generations of teachers.
The 1939 recording you'll
here now opens a little window
into performance practice.
Thinking about that, I wish that we
also had a few more of these in time
to play them like one of John
McCormick, the famous tenor,
singing Bach and Handle here
with Howard Hanson conducting
or Alfred Deller singing
renaissance songs.
You feel the charisma of
Boulanger's personality
as she demonstrates
Monteverdi on the piano.
[ Silence ]
The clip will come
up in just a second.
I should say that this Monteverdi
madrigal recording is still a sign
post for researchers.
And as a side note, Mrs. Coolidge
underwrote the complete Monteverdi
edition edited by John [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
>> Anne McLean: Boulanger
was the first woman
to conduct the Boston
Symphony Orchestra
in the New York Philharmonic.
Her concerts here, two of them
in 1939, were very modern.
They were combination
platters juxtaposing old
and newly commissioned work.
Again, these are very
forward looking ideas
that we're talking about, it's
really fascinating to go back
and read the programs
of those early years.
Conductors, let's just think
about conductors for a moment.
Given the size of our stage,
there have been a startling number
of sizable chamber orchestras
here in the early years
and many significant
conductors beginning
with the Chicago symphony's
Frederick Stock have performed here.
Stock was at the very,
very first concert.
He was a friend of Mrs. Coolidge.
This is Hans Kindler, the cellist
who was the first NSO conductor.
Ossip Gabrilowitsch who
married Mark Twain's daughter,
the contralto, Clara Clemens.
George Szell on the left, he
performed here with the Budapest.
Stokowski on the bottom
and Serge Koussevitzky.
Bernstein who performed with the
Juilliard, a racing rendition
of the [inaudible] piano quintet.
And Sir Thomas Beecham.
Beecham's 1956 lecture here
on Mozart shows us vividly how the
reputations of even the greatest
of composers come and go in
the vagaries of public opinion.
The reevaluation of
Mozart 60 years ago,
something that's really shocking
to contemplate was partly due
to Beecham's championship.
[ Silence ]
Oh, that's okay.
Beecham, he was, as you may hear in
a moment or not, it doesn't matter.
Beecham's lecture was
trenchant and funny.
And his instincts were
right on the mark.
The orchestra is a
modern invention, he said.
Do not be taken in by it and it
goes on to say, there is no promise
that the orchestra as
we know it today will be
around in 50 years' time.
That's pretty forward
looking, as I say.
Classical music has always
been the heart of the series
and our major private funds have
been given for this purpose.
Over time, the focus has expanded
growing toward the broad perspective
crucial for a national institution.
In 1928, the music division founded
the archive of American folk song,
now part of the American
folk live center.
Its focus on field recordings
capturing the essence
of live performance
meant that recording
and documenting America's vernacular
music became an important part
of the music division's mandate.
Figures like John and
Alan Lomax, later Charles
and Ruth Crawford Seeger,
and other noteworthy scholars
of American song came to work here.
This answers our question
about how the library got
into making very fine
live concert recording.
By 1937, every concert
was recorded here.
And by 1940, top flight
engineers were recording
on 16 inch acetate discs
still preserved here
with startlingly good results.
You'll hear one in a minute.
So aside from the important
documentation
of the concerts themselves, this
amazing archive offers a useful view
of American musical culture over
three quarters of a century.
For the October 1929, Coolidge
Festival of Chamber music,
folk song collector John Jacob
Nyles performed [inaudible] ballads
and African American
spirituals followed
by a jazz orchestra playing Rude
Bloom's [phonetic] Song of Bayou
and WC Handy St. Louis blues.
The conductor was the musical
polymath [phonetic] Nathaniel
Shillkret, composer,
multi instrumentalist,
and a master musical stylist.
Like a combination maybe of Paul
Schaeffer,[inaudible] the Roots,
and, you know, those days.
He was involved with the
victor talking machine company
for many years.
This is not the precise
orchestra that came here,
but it's one from that year
or very close to that time.
It's quite remarkable to see these
artists featured alongside the
flutist George Barrere,
pianist Harold Bauer,
and the conductor Leopold Stokowski.
Stokowski conducted members of
the Philadelphia orchestra here
with the [inaudible]
organ concerto and,
yes there was an organ
in the Coolidge then.
And a transcription of
JS Box the art of fugue.
A note about Stokowski, he would
soon become a vice president
of the friends of music and
the Library of Congress.
And several of you here
tonight are generous members
of our new incarnation
of that group.
The president then was Nicholas
Longworth, Speaker of the House
of Representatives and
an impressive violinist.
Stokowski would return
to the Library in 1955
and '60 conducting the symphony of
the air and making some experiments
in the Coolidge with people from
Bell Labs on stereo recording.
In 1940, the music division
celebrated the 75th anniversary
of the emancipation
proclamation with a concert series
of both classical and folk
music, including a work
by the black composer [inaudible],
and they presented the first
black solo artist to appear here,
Dorothy Maher and Roland Hayes.
Concluding it was a
milestone evening
with the poet Sterling
Brown, a landlock,
a figure from the Harlem
Renaissance,
and others including the
Golden Gate and Josh White.
And we have a clip from that
recording for that concert.
[ Music ]
It gives you an idea.
I wish we had time to
hear this whole thing
because it's very interesting.
[Inaudible] between, a main singer,
kind of a call and response person.
And then they have a choral section.
And while you're listening to it,
you flash through all the styles
that we're now currently
familiar with.
I wanted you to hear this
because of the very good sound.
That was the sound through
the 1940s, very close miched
and very high standard technically.
And let's not forget Jelly Roll
Morton's historic recording session
here in 1938.
Lomax went to meet
Morton at his night club,
the Music Box on U Street here.
He came back and asked
his boss, Harold Speevak,
the chief of the music
division, for 100 acetate discs
to record an epic recording
session that spring and summer.
Moving to another milestone
and we'll have to raise,
have to talk fast because there's
a lot of good stuff to cover.
We often talk about Gertrude Clark
Woodall Whittall's mid 1930s gift
of five [inaudible] instruments.
Another has path breaking moment.
At the time, this was the
only ensemble of its type
in North America, and for
many years the only one owned
by a government institution.
She also gave the Library
this beautiful room
and many holograph manuscripts.
Moon them ones by Broms, Beethoven,
Mozart, [inaudible] and others.
Plus Schoenberg's [inaudible], a
favorite piece from Mrs. Whittall.
Somebody asked me before I was
thinking of giving this talk
if I knew of any ghosts
associated with the series.
Perhaps, the closest thing
might be Mrs. Whittall saying
that if we programmed
[inaudible], she would come back.
I'll reveal one of the secrets
of the Coolidge auditorium.
And this is a real insider
piece of information.
It was designed not only for
chamber music but, particularly,
for beautiful string chamber
music from the very beginning.
When the acousticians were
experimenting in there.
And pausing for a sneak
preview moment, I can tell you
that next season we will present
among others the Michelangelo
Quartet, and we'll have a return
for the [inaudible] Quartet.
Acquiring our strives
led to a library first
that is now a very widespread idea
and that is a residency project.
For a time after Mrs. Whittall
chose these instruments
with Louis [inaudible] help,
they were not played regularly,
and there was some talk about hiring
musicians to come in and play them
to keep them in shape, paying
the musicians $2.50 an hour.
The Budapest Quartet would
become resident artists here
from 1940 to 1962.
Violinist Robert Mann says that in
his teen years, the Budapest was
without doubt the most famous
chamber ensemble known by name
in the world at that time.
They performed hundreds of
concerts here during their tenure.
The shot goes along with
a pregenerated PR myth
that they requested separate
tables at restaurants.
June Schneider had became the wife
of the Budapest cellist
Micha Schneider,
is still a good friend
of the Library.
I know some of you may know her,
and she's given the
inside scoop on all that.
It was just a myth.
This is their shot of their cover of
their recording with Benny Goodman.
The Juilliard.
This, I'm sorry you can't
really see these well.
But in the future, these are
brand new plasmas by their way,
and they're kind of
bigger than we're used to.
They're good, though.
Just some point we're going to
put this picture in the brochure
or in a program or news letter
because it's virtually the only one
from those years which
shows the audience.
We're going to rectify that.
Both these quartets gave memorable
and sometimes transcendent
performances
that seem almost sacral
to some music fans.
And they brought many of
their friends to perform.
George Zell.
[ Inaudible Names ]
And others who joined them in
our studio right behind the stage
where they rehearsed, ate lunch, and
sometimes watched the world series.
One even Alexander
Schneider put a pinup photo
in [inaudible] music just
before they went onstage,
an act you don't associate
with these artists.
And the mystified audience wondered
through the evening why
all four musicians seemed
to be periodically convulsed
during their performance.
When Mrs. Coolidge's ear
trumpet malfunctioned
and she could be heard speaking
very loudly in the concert hall,
he leaned, Alexander leaned
over to the audience to say
and now a word from our sponsor.
This rehearsal clip now coming
up shows our sound engineer
having the mics opened
by sheer chance during a rehearsal.
And it shows a side of the Budapest
most people would never know.
[ Music ]
That's good, yeah, thank you.
The interest of significant donors
like Mrs. Whittall have
often provided an impetus
for new directions.
By some mysterious confluence,
all the major patrons
of the Library series
have been women.
And as Sue said last month,
we'd really like to
diversify that pattern.
Mrs. Coolidge, Mrs. Whittall, the
only one who was not a musician,
Leonora Jackson McKim,
Adeline Croft a pianist
and longtime concert goer here
who underwrote a residency
for the Bozard [phonetic] Trio.
Carolyn Royal Just, an attorney but
also an amateur orchestra musician.
And now, recently, composer
and pianist Dina Koston.
We have many funds and many donors,
and I just wanted to mention a few
of them, but it is
extraordinary that they were women.
Leonora Jackson was the first
American female violinist
to be hailed in Europe.
She was a noteworthy artist who
was a student of [inaudible]
and later owned his
[inaudible] violin.
She performed with the Boston and
London orchestras among others,
and on returning from Europe had a
substantial performing career given
over 160 concerts in one year alone.
After her marriage at age 36,
she withdrew from the stage
as so many people did in
those days when they married.
We in researching Mrs. McKim
understood finally why the terms
of her bequest refer
to given funding
to American students of the violin.
Not meanly to underwrite concerts
or commissions but to give money
to fund scholarships for
American students of the violin.
The McKim fund is commissioned more
than 65 compositions for violin
and piano, several decades' worth
of styles and performance techniques
from composers like Gunther
Schuller, Elliot Carter,
Bright Sheng, and Roberto
Sierra plus [inaudible]
and McArthur winners Anthony
Braxton and Cecil Taylor.
This is a shot of a CD that was
recorded here at the Library.
And although you can't
tell, this is on stage.
And I should say that we presented
Braxton and Cecil Taylor long,
long before they were
on the McArthur radar.
The Ira and Leonore S
Gershwin fund has allowed us
to present first rate
concert versions
of many great Broadway composers.
[Inaudible] Kern, Richard
Rogers, Porter, Berlin,
Herbert, and Steven [inaudible].
And recent ones like last
fall's Broadway showcase.
And, of course, the Gershwin
prize for popular song is a new
and major direction with a huge
media presence for the Library.
I hope some of you caught the
Billy Joel program on television.
Carolyn Royal Just Fund has given
us the chance for programming
across a broad range of genres
including classical primarily
but also pop and multimedia
projects.
Dina Koston's recent bequest
allows us to look forward
to a tremendously exciting
future for new music here.
So I'll just whip through
a few images
that show an ever expanding
portfolio for the Library.
It's nice into a color
era for photographs.
This concert, this is Tito
[inaudible] performing Terry
Library's bicentennial
concert in 20000.
Also, two other [inaudible] artists
Ralph Stanley who's still very much
performing and Clarence
Gatemouth Brown who's passed away.
After this lightning overview
of the Library's concert series,
let's look at some thoughts for
the future and some observations
with some help from our
advisor, Mrs. Coolidge.
One major thing for a 90th
anniversary will be honoring our
distinguished history as a
champion of contemporary music.
The St. Lawrence Quartet
performance tonight
of a brand new John Adams
work, a Library co-commission,
makes a great springboard
towards impressive package
of 11 new commissions
within the next 90 weeks.
The line-up of composers include
a new work from Brian Ferneyhough
with the [inaudible] ensemble.
A new oratorio commission,
very unusual for the Library
by Gabriela Lena Frank,
and the work is set
to text by Ralph Waldo Emerson.
It's a co-commission with
the Handel and Haydn Society,
marking its 200th anniversary
and our 90thoonversery.
So maybe this is a good
time to mention one
of the big challenges we face, cash.
Mrs. Coolidge's check to Maurice
Ravel reminds us that in the era
of a patron like her and many
of the other major arts patrons
of the early 20th century
like Isabella Stuart
Gardener, it was very simple.
One could write a check
if one had the means.
Mrs. Coolidge did continue through
her time here to work closely
with the music division chiefs
to support things herself.
Today, it's a much more
complicated structure as we know.
We are free from the necessity
of making money and with
that luxury can avoid what
Mrs. Coolidge called, quote,
the deadening influence
of social fashion.
But our production costs alone for
one evening are currently $7,500.
So this is a challenge with
which we will need your help.
We would love to work with all our
friends to think about new ways
to fund the Library's concerts.
As we close up our conversation,
I wanted to bring back the image
of Mrs. Coolidge in the
sergeant charcoal [inaudible].
That is the most modern
image we have of her.
Today, she would be
called a media visionary
and a cultural entrepreneur.
So with her as a guide, let's wrap
up with a glimpse of the future.
Today, in an increasingly
wired world,
people are seeking
transformational experiences
in the time they spend
pursuing art and entertainment.
I'd like to make the
possibly outrageous statement
that the library has been
providing those for a long time.
How can we continue to deliver
them in the next 90 years?
And what will our challenges
and new directions be?
For all art presenters, there are
tack tonic shifts now in the concept
of culture itself and
how we consume it.
New audience research by Arthur
Cohen of [inaudible] Cohen,
the Culture Track is the
name of his firm project.
This research says that
today people are beginning
to define the cultural
experience as something
like visiting a national
park or reading a back.
Not just attending a cultural event.
And as for events, we don't have
to leave our computers
to experience them now.
Here are some statistics from an
agency called alienation digital.
In North America, around 168
million people use mobile phones.
Why not develop phone
friendly programming?
Eighty seven percent of
Americans news the Internet
and a whopping 67 percent use at
least one social network spending
at least three hours
or more a day online.
The music division's Facebook
page is increasingly popular,
I'm happy to say.
And if you haven't seen it,
you might really enjoy it.
We will be expecting to broaden our
social media presence in platforms
like Twitter which saw more than
one billion Tweets on music in 2013.
It was the most popular subject.
And other platforms like Tumblr
and Pinterest will draw our
interest and our vision.
I learned that Pinterest is very
attractive to young women 18
to 39, an interesting market.
Instagram, Reddit, many,
many platforms are available.
Is it easy to work in these
to develop programming?
No, but it will be fascinating.
In fact, the Library is
ideally suited to creating
and curating terrific
cultural content for the web.
One venture will be a plan to design
and deliver web friendly content
to take the library's
hidden wealth of knowledge
to the vast audience
of music lovers online.
We are all as a team of
programmers at the Library
from [inaudible] our chief through
our staff of the music division,
very enthusiastic about planning
public events, live streaming,
and curated web programming.
Again, a comment from Mrs.
Coolidge that's extremely timely.
Some programmer, I went to a
conference last week in New York,
the International Society for
Performing Arts Conference.
And the same question came up
there which came up with the advent
of radio which was, will radio take
away live concert audience interest?
And Mrs. Coolidge's comment
then, she really pushed forward
to have the Library go on the radio.
She said some converts conservatives
feared this radio competition
with personal appearances.
Meaning, competition
with live concerts.
But I believe that it ultimately
increased their audiences.
And, in fact, that's
what the research
that we heard last week indicates.
That people today are not merely
only going to one type of music,
they are not going to
experience music in one manner.
They like to sample
many different ways
of experience and consuming music.
Regarding demographics
and outreach, by 2020,
40 percent of the U.S. will be what
are described as minorities today.
By 2060, one third of the
potential audience for any presenter
in the performing arts
will be Hispanic.
These are arbitrary terms as
we know, but you see the drift.
It does seem certain that Americans
of all backgrounds will newt
have the elementary school music
education that most of us
in this room were fortunate
enough to receive.
Outreach for the Library will be
an ongoing challenge and will need
to increase the social
factor for public programs
as this is an increasing value
for cultural consumers under 35.
Interestingly, one research
item I learned was that oldest
and the oldest and youngest
generations do have the most
in common, free time.
It's the midrange patrons
with children,
small children particularly,
who are most pressed for time.
Social factors are going to be
tricky for Library given the issues.
We only have so much
room to socialize in.
But tonight we have a really
fun gesture in this area.
We invite you all to
visit our photo booth.
We are gathering pictures and
stories from our audience members
that we can use over the coming 90th
anniversary months in our brochure,
on the web, in newsletters.
And we also want to hear from
you how long have you been coming
to the Library, what's
your experience about it?
And when you came in, you
probably saw the photo booth set up
and wondered what is
this, what, what?
So if you have time,
please join us there,
and we'd love to have your photo.
With outreach in general, we
invoke our founders' name again
with admiration.
She was the guru of outreach really
sponsoring thousands of programs
in educational institutions
nationwide.
Run outs to interesting
venues and collaborations
with other institutions will
be a part of our future.
We'll be continuing the crucial
mandate to serve Congress
and the American people
and underscoring the goal
of cultural democracy.
Representing a diversity of
musical expression to an audience
that is diverse is important
throughout the decades.
You've probably noticed
our tagline this season,
an exclusive experience
for everyone.
Being able to work for a concert
series that is offered free
to the public is a
remarkable privilege.
Marketers advise to us
presenters multiple means
of engagement with our audiences.
For radio, we're 90 for 90 now.
We've been on the air
an astonishing 90 years.
We have a new radio series in
Washington on WETA that will come
up in march and around the country.
Stay tuned also for some
new directions in radio
for a 2015/16 season and
its contemporary music.
I won't say anything
more about that.
I will show a couple of photos,
these are just a few, a few.
And as I say, you are all the
recipients of the sneak preview.
These are just a few of the
eleven or possibly 12 commissions
that we have coming up next
year within the next 90 months.
One is in March, you will probably
hear, some of you will hear it,
and you may know about it already.
Jennifer Higdon with the Curtis
Orchestra and Roberto Diaz.
Brian Ferneyhough from Stanford.
He will be premiering, we will
be premiering a new work from him
with a large chamber ensemble.
Gabriela Lena Frank is the composer
of the oratorio that I mentioned
with Handel and Haydn Society.
And the last person is Paul Landsky.
We'll have a woodwind quintet.
And also, I'm coming to
the end of my time here,
but I wanted to mention
a very exciting program.
We didn't have the time to
get into Aaron Copeland,
but Copeland is an example of
a composer, one among many,
within the Library as had a
long relationship over decades.
And it's fascinate to see from his
very early letters to Mrs. Coolidge
and letters that show his interest
in getting a commission from her.
Then you move through the era of
Copeland planning [inaudible] Spring
with Martha Graham and Harold
Speevak, the former chief
for many years and Mrs.
Coolidge who was very,
very hands on in that commission.
You move through that and the
time period in which it looks
like [inaudible] Spring would very
nearly be written for two pianos
because that's what they
might have been able to score
for in the timeframe they had.
We have a huge documentation,
of course,
for that work in our archives.
And then at the end of his
career, we released a recording
of his 81st birthday here
which is on Bridge Records.
And it's charming because he talks
about, again, it's like a view
into the past through the
viewfinder of a kaleidoscope.
But back to Nadia Boulanger.
He talks about how in the books he
says everyone thinks I went to Paris
to study Nadia Boulanger,
I didn't know who she was.
And he said I didn't
want to tell my folks
that I was studying with a woman.
I'm paraphrasing, but
it's very funny.
And he has the instincts
of a comedian while
he's doing all of this.
So I raise Copeland because, again,
it underscores one of the themes
of my talk which is relationships
throughout these many years we've
been in business.
And we want to honor the
Copeland/Graham relationship
and the path breaking
ballet that they created.
We will be mounting [inaudible]
Spring again April next year.
And the Martha Graham Company
will be here for two days.
But we will also have a
brand new dance commission.
I can't say too much more than that,
but we're putting the final touches
now to some contracts and so on.
So it's very exciting.
I'll just say in wrapping this
up that I asked someone last week
to give me a two word response to
the idea of the Library series.
And she said venerable
and adventurous.
We want to in this coming 90
weeks honor Mrs. Coolidge's
adventurous spirit.
One of the most fun things I know
about her is that she spent a lot
of time in 1920s trying
to find a way
to bring a [inaudible]
orchestra to the Coolidge.
Time and space are on their
last legs, I think, she said.
This is a fascinating comment
in the pre-Internet age.
And we shall all have
to re-educate our senses
to interpret a new set
of sensory impressions.
Today, as I said, she would
be called a visionary.
She remains startlingly focused
example of someone with instincts
for presenting great art.
She stated her goal
as, quote, to serve art
and through art to serve humanity.
Following with, quote, the survival
of the human spirit largely
depends upon its artistic freedom.
Pointing it especially
in the past month.
Music is a mechanism
to approach the divine.
This is a statement
I noted down once
but have never found the source.
If you know it or can
find it, let me know.
However one might define
the concept of the divine,
I know that as presenters
and audience members,
we share in making
this approach together.
We look forward tremendously
to celebrating the Library's
90th anniversary with you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.